let's talk now about that reelection.
This is an interesting story that I want to
be careful about because when I talk about
this, I don't want to inadvertently make anybody
think that maybe they don't need to go out
and vote in November.
Everybody needs to go out and vote in November.
But it's an interesting story.
Nonetheless.
Donald Trump is the most unpopular president
as of January one of their reelection year
to seek reelection dating back all the way,
44 years to Gerald Ford seeking reelection
in 1976 and Donald Trump's still might win
despite that.
Um, according to five 38 on January 1st just
a few days ago, Donald Trump's approval rating
was 42.6%.
This might now be lower because of the Iran
stuff or it might be higher.
We don't really know, but that was the number
as of January 1st only Gerald Ford had a lower
approval rating on January one of an election
year of reelection year who was pulling 39.3%
on January 1st of 1976.
Now, my memory when I was starting to research
this yesterday was that George W. Bush was
very unpopular when running for reelection,
and indeed he was at 48.9% approval, but that
was higher than Barack Obama at 45.7% Barack
Obama winning reelection very easily in 2012
so there's a few important messages here.
The most important one is if George W. Bush
was reelected with a 48.9% approval on January
one of his reelection year, if Barack Obama
was reelected with 45.7% approval on January
one of his reelection year, Trump can be reelected
at 42.6% especially in this hyper-partisan
environment where Trump is likely to lose
the popular vote because of big deficits and
large blue States like California and New
York.
But to eke out winds in those few key States
that handed him the electoral college victory
in 2016 so when you see this, it's interesting.
We don't know how Trump's approval will, will
move between now and election day.
It means nothing about whether we need to
get out and vote.
The answer is yes, we do.
The other thing to remember is that November
approval need not be anything like January
1st approval.
And in fact, if you look at the last 11 presidents
who ran for reelection of the 11 six saw their
approval go down between January 1st and the
election five saw their approval go up between
January 1st and the election.
So for Trump, this means to get out of the
danger zone.
He needs to try to get his approval closer
to 50%.
For us, this means assume nothing, vote work.
Every state, consider no state's safe.
I mean, we know California, Massachusetts
in New York, we know that they're going blue,
but work, the election work, every state.
Trump was one of the most disliked and unpopular
candidates that ran, right?
I mean, remember before he was elected, he
was extremely unpopular within the Republican,
a, um, a primary and he still won.
We are fighting some of the most malignantly
ignorant people in the country to try to remove
this guy.
Incumbency is a powerful thing.
We need to fight it on all fronts.
Public activism, get out the vote.
We've gotta be fighting voter suppression
that is happening in many States and we are
trying to fight it in many of those States,
fight gerrymandering, fight the foreign influence,
which is of course going to be an issue once
again.
And to put sort of like a final point on this,
despite Gerald Ford's approval rating of only
39% back in 1976 he lost the popular vote
by only a million and a half votes.
That's about half of the margin that Trump
lost by in 2016.
Put another way as unpopular as Gerald Ford
was in 1976, Trump lost the popular vote by
twice as much in 2016 and still won the electoral
college.
So the takeaway is don't do anything that
would be influenced by thinking that it's
in the bag.
I still believe that it is more than plausible
that Donald Trump gets himself reelected.
Sometimes people, you know, when, whenever
I let, let's actually address that because
we are going to have a long, uh, election
cycle here of this.
I, I've said many times, I am against Donald
Trump.
I think there's a great chance that Donald
Trump is defeated, but I think it's perfectly
plausible.
And in some cases, if certain things go a
certain way, even likely that Donald Trump
gets himself reelected.
And when I say that, I'll get emails from
people in the audience who say, David, you're
being really demoralizing by saying you think
Donald Trump could get reelected.
Uh, I'm being realistic with you.
And if anything, when you hear me say that
it shouldn't demoralize you, it should make
you commit to voting and to getting out the
vote.
The idea that stating that the president could
realistically get himself reelected is the
moralizing is the absolute wrong interpretation.
The interpretation should be half of the country
doesn't vote.
Let's go out and get people voting so that
we can win this thing.
Let's go to a break afterwards.
Uh, CNBC put up the wrong pictures of Andrew
Yang and tool C Gabbert and a recent segment
I want to talk with you about whether it is
ignorance or malice, and we will of course
raise Hanlon's razor.
Always
a great quote when we talk about ignorance
versus malice, your voicemails and many other
things coming up.
The David Pakman